well they say everything old is new
again and that's certainly the case with
this latest trend the unyielding terror
of being annihilated by nuclear war and
you thought mom jeans were bad a train
crash this morning left 15 injured and
derailed many morning commutes just
derailed that is a that's a gem it's
unfortunate though the actual thing that
happened moving on in other news for
abandoned puppies found their forever
homes thanks to a local humane society
as previously reported these puppies and
their three siblings who did not make it
we're left to die in a local dumpster
wow that one didn't even have a pun
that's just tragic but it gives a new
meaning to the term litter of puppies oh
there it is in the end you could have
your light-hearted riff joke ha Darryl
what the [ __ ]
sorry we're off no we're aren't good
well drop to the f-bomb the opioid
crisis has hit local communities hard
and things seem to be getting worse the
death toll has been hitting record highs
haha hi Darryl what are you smoking to
make you think that that's ok it's 8
a.m. buddy and he put it in italics -
that's something you couldn't see so
that's just at my expense you don't even
know that that's just a joke between
Darryl and I as if we're friends which
we are not italicize not there's a big
break in the case of a local
schoolteachers death led police to
arrest two students in connection with
the crime a fire started in the
chemistry lab causing the death of one
Andrew Barnett what the [ __ ] Darryl a
man's dead why is every news story I
have to have a pun that's all I'm saying
you're writing it has a rhyme or a pun
just because you wanted to be a comedic
rapper we everyone at home has to suffer
well here's the good news no matter what
horrible tragedy befalls you you can
rest easy knowing that you will bring a
small measure of joy to a dead soul of a
news copywriter as they discover the
perfect pun to describe your death see
you tomorrow baby
[Music]